he's the most necessary voice in the
world today in america today period
rogan is the most necessary voice in
america today listen let me put it to
you this way
everybody better protect this guy
everybody better protect this guy
because if he you know some people are
saying well he's kind of also being
bullied to not talk about it was like
hey he's going to go back to only
talking about hallucinogen you know
mushrooms and aliens and all that and
he's going away from covet right they're
kind of pulling him for him to be
silenced in a way
you have to know that is a very very
necessary guy but here's the big butt
this is the big bot
and it's what i said to rogan when i
went on the uh podcast with him
and i i was doing my best to get him to
think about this and i think it's
actually gonna happen to be honest with
you i think it's gonna happen
i think
here's what i'm convinced
say spotify they went from a 70 billion
dollar company a year and a half ago the
market hasn't tanked
they've lost they went from a 60 billion
dollar company to a 36 billion dollar
company they've lost 24 billion dollars
almost cut in half since signing rogan
okay now this is not a rogan thing
they've just lost that much during that
time
neil young alone they lost four billion
on this one guy and if all these other
guys show up they lose money now let me
give you a complete different aspect uh
perspective on this
let's say spotify do what do you think
of the chance of spotify drop in rogan
give me a percentage
no i don't know zero no it's not zero
you can't say zero this is i don't i
think there would be you cannot say zero
such insane
backlash another spot give me the number
less than two percent you think it's
less than two percent what do you think
canceling rogan to me to me i'm going to
put it at 50 if they're losing that
amount of money
okay i think it's 10
i don't think it's 50 but i'm 10 okay 2
50 40 10
fine here's the thing let's say they do
it
let's go there okay
spotify if you're listening to this
let's say you go there okay
no no actually go there
i'm there
you're gonna see if this happens what
happens
go ahead and cancel rogan
what who's the first person that's gonna
call rogan
give me the first person that's gonna
call roman apple music no i'm sorry no
no
one person is going to call rogan it's
the first phone call if rogan gets
cancer elon musk elon musk is going to
call royalties
elon musk is going to call rogan saying
here's 20 billion dollars let's go whoop
everyone's ass then elon's gonna say
we're hiring
for engineers
me and rogan have teamed up with peter
thiel we're hiring engineers we're
hiring developers we're giving big ass
bonuses and equity come on down let's
whoop everyone's ass
and that's going to be elon rogan and
theo who do you think is going to go on
that website
an elon musk they just called him jv of
evie
biden said jv of evie they're not even
inviting him to the white house again
and and elon musk if you see elon musk
what he said about biden this last week
i don't know if you saw what ilama said
about biden this is not favorable no of
course it's not favorable because you're
talking about tesla when you think about
ev you know uh uh uh when you think
about ev you think about uh uh electric
vehicles
what other name do you think about you
don't think
you know think about nobody else no and
by the way somebody said ximena said
donald trump i disagree
that's not the right guy to bring behind
it because that would not help the cause
i think it's elon musk rogan peter thiel
if spotify drops him so here's the thing
why would a why would a elon musk need a
peter thiel yeah peter thiel oh my gosh
you must not know who peter thiel is i
know who he is but why would elon need
him you don't need him but you need them
okay because peter thiel is a true
believer and again here's a guy that's a
gay libertarian who has strong beliefs
but has everything in silicon valley all
roads lead to peter thiel you don't
peter thiele mafia he's an underground
tough guy brilliant guy you don't mess
with that guy that guy's a genius you
put those three together then guess what
everybody's doing everyone's shivering
everybody is shaking if those three guys
back up so so to me
i do think like right now how old is
rogan today rogan's how old he's i say
his early 50s 50 53 okay how old is uh
start
rogan is he's gotta be late he's 54.
okay how old is stern go stern age i'm
guessing 66.
oh
his age is what 68. okay you're by the
way he just signed like a 10-year
contract then he's 60. so he's going to
go to 78. okay would you say rogan's a
young 54 year old can we say rogan's a
young 54 year old okay so watch this
watch this watch this
so
rogan musk is what 50
yes musk is also around the same age so
if these guys teamed up and they started
recruiting people
it would be game over
so so there is a side there is a side
that
i dare spotify to do something i dare i
double dare you elon would make it a
mission
of his to go out there and do this it
would be bad news for a lot of people in
silicon valley and spotify it would be
great news for free thinkers for
entrepreneurs for those that just want
to sit there and say i disagree with you
can we sit down and have a conversation
have some banter that's what i think so
the concern about if if if joe you know
by himself not wife's not around girls
are not around daughters are not around
friends are not around
joey's not around all these other people
are not on that he talks to regularly
he's by himself you're in the car by
yourself driving your security nobody's
around you he's sitting there and it's
like
man what if spotify drops me okay
i would say
i dared him to drop me
it would be more from that perspective
because then
right now he's got a lot of followers
now you're going to go into
you know legendary
no no no it's game over type of le
you're talking about now you have a
world type of influence at the next
level because now you dictate now ilan
you know joe's gonna be like okay let me
get a handful of these guys that i
like their strategies let's go recruit
what do you think that phone calls sound
like hey i'm joe rogan i notice you have
a podcast we like to have you come to
xyz company with me elon musk
so so yeah i i i imagine yeah i by the
way i i
i don't know why i want to see that
so do i i want to see that you know how
that idea starts by the way how it's
just them too on a podcast one big fat
ass joint elon musk taking a hit rogan
encouraging them and then boom
i feel like that's happening we are
recruiting people if you want to be in
text us at this number here's a link go
subscribe
let's start so i don't know so to me
you know
people have to protect joe and i think
elon in a way is a protector of ideas i
think elon and a handful of other people
who are very powerful in their own way
boom let's go and they're going to go
elon actually has those types of
aspirations to putting together what are
you talking about media that's not
coming to him
the guy wants to go marry aliens
according to what you want to say he was
going to live on mars so if he wants to
go on mars this this
what's harder living on mars or kicking
everyone's ass on silicon valley i'm
sorry it's living on mars this is
nothing to them it's chump change
i think that they they could do that or
that that's a possibility uh that's not
gonna influence whether or not spotify
drops them i i think
they're going to look at it purely as a
business move is that if it gets to the
point where enough people say if you
don't drop them we leave and and their
bottom line gets to a certain number
then they'll get rid of them just based
on that kind of irrespective of what
they think but is there number
hemorrhaging because of rogan that can't
be the reason i mean i'm sure it's
impossible to quantify i have no doubt
that there's a lot of factors to it but
you know to me
again like at some point if they just
continue to lose and lose and i mean i'm
i'm still sitting here a little bit
reeling from the fact that
that uh neil young cost him 4 billion by
leaving how the [ __ ] is that even
possible
uh
spotify lost 4 billion from him type it
to me that's surprising i guess but uh i
i'd be shocked if people under 30 even
knew who neil young was i mean but and
that's the thing right in spotify like
if you look at a lot of older musicians
like they have very small followings on
there most of them look at that right
there spotify loses 4 billion in market
value after neil young controversy
that's crazy yeah so so you think it's
not an impact it's an impact so i
guarantee the board there's no way
they're not looking at that the board
has got so much pressure listen
listen i'm telling you right now joe
ilan peter i'm telling you
two to three have plenty of experience
running companies going up against
bigger enemies i mean tesla went up
against who's a bigger mafia than ford
gm chrysler toyota tell me who's a
bigger mafia
who is a bigger mafia you go take their
lunch
are you kidding me this guy took their
lunch
this is no joke this is not an easy
industry to take their lunch you're
talking about that guy he didn't say let
me create a new website called
facebook and let's go create something
new he said what does everybody use a
car let me go make cars what
and beat everybody that's that's hard
that this is not hard that's hard so
yeah so if this keeps happening stuff
like this let me make your job easier
for you spotify i resign okay
you paid me a hundred million dollars no
problem elon's willing to pay me a
billion dollars elon will sign a 1
billion 20-year contract with joe rogan
that's what he would do in a heartbeat
hey joe
50 million a year for 20 years do the
podcast on my show that's what elon
would do okay and 50 million a year to
elon musk is what it's like you going to
starbucks okay he ain't even gonna feel
it okay he's gonna say joe don't worry
about it drop spotify send a letter
resignation it's become too much of a
frustration let's go whoop some ass
together everybody would be [ __ ]
bricks
everybody would be calling their mommy
saying mommy you will not believe joe oh
my gosh what do we do everybody would be
in tears saying this is the one guy
crazy enough that can pull it off that
is the one guy because
when you when you push when you push
true believers
who are the best at what they do who are
number one not complainers that quit and
then they say i'm jo you ain't joe bro
you're like number you know when
somebody leaves a company and i'm going
to go do i'm going to be the next joe no
no no there's only one show in the world
there's only one elon musk in the world
if that happens
game over oh my god
do you know what that's like frasier
against ali forget about it
trump hillary forget about it i mean who
do you want to put in there big magic
against jordan 1990 1991 forget about it
you know jordan against pistons forget
about it this is gonna be
the underdogs against the bullies
let's go bully the hell out of the
bullies
these are the guys that are the ragtag
people that are showing up
let's go it would be freaking
entertainment at the highest level now
maybe i'm just dreaming yeah
pat just went you went somewhere with
that by the way you're on fire right now
but i tell you i don't want you to stop
but i tell you but i tell you i'm
telling you right now i fully tell you
right now
the biggest insurance policy
is being
a worker is being fair
is being a chill guy that people like
it's being humble yet competitive and
deliver on the product willing to
constantly improve you track the right
people in your life this morning i did a
video about talking about the biggest
currency to invest into more than
bitcoin
more than ethereum more than any stock
more than gold more than anything
there's nothing
more valuable than big everybody wants
to get some more bitcoin in their net in
their wallet or whatever it is
yeah there is no currency more valuable
than your attitude there is no currency
more valuable than your attitude no
currency more valuable than your
attitude your attitude is why you're
here
you and i met at an insurance event for
eight years we didn't do nothing every
year i saw your attitude i'm like what i
can't wait to meet that guy what's the
guy i don't know his name but i like
meeting this guy adam what's up and hey
this is adam hey let me add them you got
to do content
your attitude is the most expensive
currency you have money
that's fine you have crypto that's fine
your attitude is worth 20 times more
than all the one you've got in the world
look at joe's attitude it's freaking
attractive look at elon's attitude it's
attractive and some people don't like
attractive attitude that attitude is
worth billions forget the 100 million
dollar contract you can't teach joe's
attitude that attitude is very very
attractive
and the attitude you know what's the
best thing about a great attitude you
know what's the great thing about a big
ad what business are you and i earned
what industry are we insurance financial
services there is not a bigger insurance
policy than a great attitude
because you're protected for the rest of
your life because your attitude who can
take your attitude away from you
it's yours
every organization every company every
city every state every country wants
people with better attitudes it goes
back to your voting system and your book
that you talk about where the 500 people
and the people that have done most for
that it's what it's a form of an
attitude you want to contribute to your
society yeah to the society you live in
so yeah i mean they're not going to
they're not going to nominate people
with shitty attitudes no they're not you
know they're just not going to do it and
by the way we're not going to bring
somebody back on our podcast with a
shitty added to three times
your attitude is freaking awesome you
know it goes to you
you know your attitude is sick everybody
every time you come here it's attractive
there's something here's a navy seal
that if you wanted to could go out there
and do a lot of harm to people just the
chill guy you're talking to laughing
chopping it up different kind of
conversation so i don't know more and
more i'm getting excited about this more
and more i kind of want to see this
happen yeah as you went there
are you bumping it up no no i'm 10 that
spotify will drop
but i tell you
the biggest bad ass move would be
oh
so you're ten percent on spotify
dropping rogan but but where are you at
on rogan's saying like you said i don't
even see this
i'm going to send the message to mom say
joe watch rarely send just watch this
and just please consider it joe just
please consider it okay just please
consider it i'm telling you and elon
you're watching this
sign a billion dollar contract with joe
for 20 years
you can do it i bet he'd do it for free
by the way no no joe wouldn't do it joe
doesn't need to do it for free because
joe's attitude and the way he does
things is worth a billion dollars
minimal
if if i was running a media company
joe's a billion dollar 20-year contract
that joseph minimum i'm not even telling
you hi alone that's a minimum joe's a 50
million dollar a year guy for 20 years
and by the way you know this isn't like
i'm trying to get on rogan this isn't
like how some people like oh people say
good things about you because they want
to get on rogue and i was out on the
road can you wait a great time
yeah no i'm saying this because i'm
telling you joe's a billion dollar net
worth attitude and ilan needs to come
out and say i'm signing a 20 or 1
billion dollar contract with joe for joe
to do his podcast on the network that
i'm creating i think that's what needs
to happen and that is the biggest power
move oh my people would by the way check
this out watch this now watch this now
uh this friday i'm having a meeting with
uh a very powerful ceo of a major social
media company that you all know about
he's coming here we're gonna have dinner
together today's wednesday what is today
today is thursday tomorrow night yeah
maybe we'll go to dinner as well so it's
tomorrow night right
um
trump starts in that the truth network
who's going to join the network
who do you think
do you think aoc is going to be on that
network no no but she needs to be okay
if she's wants to do a debate but not
really but watch this if elon and joe
and peter thiel
started network who would be on that
everybody left right center up down i
don't know i don't think aoc would be
but here's who would be if this is alex
jones
if this is aoc and uh uh young turks and
who else you want to put it you're
bernie yeah
everybody guys if this is center these
guys would be on